hi
i'm bill kuzmal this is joint work with
alec westover
and the title of this talk is the
variable processor cup game
i want to start by telling you about a
classic problem known as the single
processor cup game
in this problem there are n cups each
cup is capable of holding an arbitrarily
large amount of water
so here the water is shown in gray and
there are two players
a filler and an emptier
at the beginning of each step of the
game the filler gets to distribute
one unit of water among the cups however
they want so here that
that unit of water is shown in blue
then the emptier gets to select a single
cup
and remove up to one unit of water from
just that cup
so here the empty removed from the
second cup
and the emptier's goal is to minimize
what's known as the backlog of the
system
which is defined to be the amount of
water in the fullest cup
you can also think of this as being a
scheduling problem
so the cups represent tasks the water in
the cups represent work that needs to be
completed on those tasks
and when the filler puts water into the
cups that represents new work
arriving for the tasks then when the
emptyer
selects a cup and removes a unit of
water from that cup
that corresponds to that task being
scheduled to run for a time step
and complete one unit of work that's how
you can think of this as a scheduling
problem
and extending that a little further you
arrive at
a generalization of this known as the p
processor cup game
so the p processor cup game is the same
problem but it generalizes to what
happens
if you get to run multiple tasks at once
so now instead of the filler placing one
unit of water into the cups at each step
the filler places p units of water into
the cups
placing no more than one unit into any
particular cup
and then the emptier instead of
selecting a single cup
now gets to select p different cups and
remove up to one unit of water
from each of those cups so in this
example p
equals three and these are the three
cups that the empty removes water from
so that's what happens at every step and
again the emptier's goal is to minimize
the backlog which is the height of the
fullest cup
one of the classic algorithms for this
problem is the greedy algorithm
what does the greedy algorithm do well
in each step it just removes water
from the p fullest cups so the greedy
algorithm
is an algorithm for the emptier and
after a long line of research what we
know about the greedy algorithm
is that it achieves a pretty good
backlog it achieves a backlog
of big o of log n and it actually does
that no matter what the value of p
is moreover this turns out to actually
be asymptotically optimal
so no deterministic emptying algorithm
can do better
there's also been a whole bunch of other
directions of work on
on cup games so there's been work on
randomized algorithms
there's been work on smooth analysis
what happens if you randomly perturb
the starting state of the cup game
there's been work on restricted fillers
for example what happens if you consider
a filler that always puts the same
amount of water
into a given cup from step to step
there's been work on competitive
analysis resource augmentation
there's been other directions too such
as semi-clairvoyance and
you know other assumptions about the
empty and the filler
and what all of these research
directions have shared in common
is one common assumption which is that
the number of processors p is fixed
and so that's the assumption that we're
going to be playing with in this talk
what happens if we let p vary
and this is motivated in part by the
fact that on real systems it's becoming
increasingly the common case
that that many applications are running
on the same system at once
and that means from the perspective of a
single application the amount of
resources that are available to it
will vary over time the number of
processors available to it the amount of
cash available to it
the amount of memory available to it and
so on
one line of research that's been very
active recently has been trying to
understand what happens when the amount
of cash available to an application
fluctuates over time this has led to the
study of what are known as
cash adaptive algorithms but what's much
less well understood is what happens
if the number of available processors
fluctuates over time
and that's the question we want to
address today for the p processor cup
game
to do that we introduced this notion of
what we call the variable processor cup
game
and this works exactly like the standard
p processor cup game
except now the variable p the parameter
p
varies over time it's a function of the
step number t
and so besides that it's exactly the
same the only difference is that now
p changes over time
now one thing i want to point out is
that it isn't really fundamentally
necessary that we
that the filler should have the same
value of p as the emptier on each step
the reason we assume that though is that
way it's kind of a fair fight it makes
it so that
the amount of water the filler puts in
in each step is the same as the amount
of water that the emptier
can remove and so by making it a fair
fight
we make it a problem that where the
emptier has
where the emptier should be able to have
a chance of doing well
so actually when we started working on
this problem we actually thought this
would be kind of
a straightforward exercise and the
reason for that is that for each
individual value of p in the p processor
cup game
the optimal the optimal backlog is log n
in other words the optimal backlog has
nothing to do with your choice of p
and so we thought that for sure what
would happen is that
if you let p change over time the
optimal backlog would again
remain order log n
but what we were surprised to find was
our intuition was actually completely
wrong
so we ended up the first thing we ended
up showing is that the optimal backlog
bound that you can get for the greedy
emptying algorithm ends up being now
big o of n instead of big o of log n
so before the greedy emptying algorithm
achieved backlog
log n now it achieves backlog roughly
n so the backlog has exploded
but it turns out that's actually not the
greedy emptying algorithm's fault
and that's because it turns out now the
optimal backlog in the variable
processor cup game
actually is omega of n so for any
deterministic emptying algorithm
there's a corresponding filling strategy
that achieves backlog omega of n
within two to the n steps that's what we
prove
and so what that means is that actually
the greedy emptying algorithm is still
optimal
it's just that the optimal backlog now
is actually much larger than it was
before
so when we first proved this result we
were kind of shocked because we hadn't
expected these two games to be so
different than each other
and the first thing we wondered is we
said well this second theorem
this construction takes an awfully long
time it takes time two to the n
and so we wondered maybe if you consider
shorter games maybe then
the backlog becomes smaller again
and so that led us to consider games
that were quasi-polynomial length so
games that have length 2 to the poly log
n
and kind of remarkably again it turns
out
the backlog is still huge
so what we were able to prove is for any
deterministic emptying algorithm
and for any constant parameter epsilon
greater than zero
there's a filling strategy strategy that
achieves backlog
n to the one minus epsilon within
quasi-polynomial time
and there's an interesting gap here
because of course the upper bound is big
o of n
and now our lower bound is n to the one
minus epsilon
and i think this is an interesting open
question whether or not
that epsilon is necessary i don't know
the answer
the next thing we started to wonder
about was well this emptier
this the second theorem assumes that the
empty is a deterministic algorithm
but what if the empty is a randomized
algorithm
why would that help well if the is a
randomized algorithm
then you assume that the filler is
what's known as an oblivious adversary
that means the filler's blind they can't
see what the emptier is doing
they can't see what the state of the
cups are
and that means that the empty can in
turn use their randomization to try to
make it so the filler doesn't know
what's going on
in order to try to hamper the filler's
efforts and keep the backlog small
what we considered in our paper were
randomized emptying algorithms that are
that satisfy a certain property known as
being greedy-like
so an emptying algorithm is greedy-like
what that means is
if it's trying to choose between two
cups to empty out of
and one of the cups contains
significantly more water than the other
then a greedy-like algorithm will always
prefer the cup that contains
significantly more water
but if the algorithm is choosing between
cups that have a similar amount of water
to each other
then the algorithm is allowed to use its
randomness and pick between those cups
however it wants
that's what it means to be a randomized
greedy-like algorithm
and what's interesting is again the
you know it doesn't really change the
outcome the randomization
doesn't help with the situation we're
still in a situation
where a filler can actually force a
backlog of n to the one minus epsilon
that's what we proved
and of course there's an interesting
open question here too which is
what happens if you remove this
greedy-like assumption what happens if
you consider
just an arbitrary randomized empty
algorithm
is there still a filling strategy that
forces a backlog of n to the one minus
epsilon
and again i don't know what the answer
to that should be
so this was where our results brought us
is that even if your empty is allowed to
be randomized
as long as they satisfy a little bit of
structure they're greedy-like
then still the filler can force a large
backlog
and when you put these results together
you start to get a kind of interesting
story
which is that these two games the
variable processor cup game
and the p processor cup game really are
fundamentally different
the backlog for the variable processor
cup game really is fundamentally larger
than for its p processor counterpart
and i think this raises an interesting
direction for future work
which is to try to understand whether
the separation between those two games
whether that persists in the presence of
beyond worst case analysis
so what if you consider resource
augmentation
what if you consider you know for
example smooth
analysis or restricting the rate at
which the filler can change
uh p over time you know
when you when you consider these forms
of beyond worst case analysis
is it still the case that these two
games are so different from each other
i think that's a fascinating question
okay so what i want to do in the rest of
the talk is i want to give you a sense
for
why the filler can cause such a large
backlog in the variable processor cup
game
how does develop how does the filler
achieve a backlog
of omega n
to be more precise our goal is going to
be to achieve a backlog of n minus 1
over 2
on incomes that's our goal
and the way we're going to do that is
with a recursive construction
and so we're going to have an inductive
hypothesis which is that we already know
how to do our goal
on n minus 1 cups what that means is
that on n minus
1 cups we know how to achieve a backlog
of n minus 2
over 2. then we're going to use this
inductive hypothesis recursively in
order to achieve our goal
on n cups now in order to be able to
visualize this inductive hypothesis the
way we're going to think of this is that
you start with n
minus 1 empty cups you apply this
golden box which represents our
inductive hypothesis
and boom you get a cup with n minus 2
over 2 water
that's how we'll be visualizing our
inductive hypothesis when we use it in
our recursive construction
now i can tell you what we do how how we
recursively
construct our algorithm for the n cups
case how do we force a backlog
of omega n in the n cubs case
the first thing we do is we use our
recursive construction on the first
n minus 1 cups we apply our inductive
hypothesis and
boom we get a cup with n minus 2 over 2
units of water now of course this isn't
actually what we want what we want is a
cup that has 0.5
additional units of water on top of this
but it's a good start
okay so what do we do next well the next
thing we do is we focus
on cut on the remaining n minus one cups
and we apply
our inductive hypothesis to those
but here we have to be very careful
because what might happen is that while
we're applying our inductive hypothesis
to these cups
the emptier might remove water from this
first cup
which would be bad for us because we
really want that cup to maintain its
fill
so in order to prevent the emptier from
doing that
we do what i call freezing this cup so
how does it work
well we're applying this inductive
hypothesis in each step of that
recursive construction
we then increase p further by one so we
make p one larger than the recursive
construction wants it to be
and then that lets us put one extra unit
of water into the cups
and we place that unit of water in each
step we place it into this first cup
the fact that we made p1 larger means
the emptyer also gets to remove
from one water from one extra cup but
the empty is going to have to do
is they're going to always have to
remove it from this first cup
because if they don't then what's going
to happen is that first cup is going to
have the backlog that we were aiming for
and our construction will just be done
so in each step of of the while we're
applying the inductive hypothesis over
here
we also put one unit of water into the
first cup and have it removed by the
emptier
repeatedly and what that lets us achieve
is that when we're done with our
inductive hypothesis
we now have two cups each of which have
n minus two over two units of water in
them
and this brings us to the final step of
our recursive construction
what we do now is we set p
to be one so now we're in the single
processor cup game
and then we just put 0.5 units of water
into each of these two cups
because p equals one the emptier can
only empty out of one of the two cups
and that means we win
because the other cup the one the
emptier didn't empty out of
that cup now has n minus one over two
units of water
which is exactly what our goal was
so that's how using a recursive
construction and by
changing p dynamically during this
recursive construction the filler can
force a backlog
of n minus one over two
and as we talked about before there's
several downsides with this basic
construction
so what are they well the first downside
as we talked about before is that this
construction takes
exponential time it takes time two to
the n roughly
why is that well in order to do the
construction on end cups we have to
twice apply the construction on n minus
one cups
and if you induct then the running time
ends up growing exponentially
and so as i talked about before kind of
one of the core technical pieces of the
paper is showing how to
provide a different construction that
still works
for shorter games games that have
quasi-polynomial length
another drawback of this construction is
that it really requires the filler to be
an adaptive adversary
and the place where it does that is
actually at the end when the filler has
to figure out
which of these two cups is the cup that
has backlog n minus one over two
and the filler has to be able to do that
not just here but also
in the recursive steps of the algorithm
at the end of every recursive step it
has to figure out
what's the cup that actually has the
large amount of water that i was aiming
for
and so when you make the filler be an
oblivious adversary that really changes
the construction and kind of
one of the key technical challenges in
the paper was figuring out how
to come up with a construction for the
filler that worked against
randomized greedy-like emptying
algorithms
so those were some of the challenges
that we overcame in the paper
but the the core idea is still
basically this this idea that with a
recursive construction in the variable
processor cup game
the backlog becomes much larger than it
ever would have been
in the p processor cup game for any
fixed value of p
i want to conclude the talk by coming
back to this slide that we saw earlier
the slide with some directions for
future work and
now that we've actually seen a
construction for how the filler can
force such a large backlog in the
variable processor cup game
i think we can also now better
appreciate why these directions of work
seems so promising
and that's because this construction
seems kind of fragile
it's this recursive construction where
the number of processors p
varies in this kind of fractal-like way
and it seems like
it seems like that construction it it's
hard to tell whether that kind of
construction would be robust
to beyond worst case analysis
so what would happen for example with
resource augmentation what that means is
that now
the empty is actually allowed to remove
a little more water and aggregate than
the filler put in
in at each step or what happens for
example if we place
restrictions on the filler so for
example we restrict the rate at which p
varies i think these questions are kind
of
really fundamental questions if we want
to understand the difference between the
variable processor cup game
and its p processor counterpart thank
you very much
you